well the month of may is focused on
bringing awareness to mental health and
it's something very common especially
during the pandemic
and it's also treatable christian
casadas joining us now live from the
newsroom on
how to know when it's time to get help
not only for adults but also for
children too christian
that's right denise well mental illness
does not discriminate it can affect any
of us at any time however
if ignored it can cause not only
emotional symptoms but
physical too and it can also affect the
people around you now may
as you mentioned is a mental health
awareness month and
a reminder that there is help therapy
and
medication one in five people or 20
percent of americans
suffer from a psychiatric illness which
could slowly impact your work and
relationships
not only do adults suffer from mental
illness teens and children
do too lisa durrett with unlv school of
medicine says the pandemic played
a big role especially with kids being
out of school and away from friends and
activities
she says there are several signs parents
should look out for
if in your children you see any decline
in their school performance just like we
talk about a decline in work performance
with an adult
especially little kids a lot of physical
complaints headaches tummy aches
more fidgetiness temper tantrums that
just don't seem
to match the situation or threatening to
hurt themselves
well for teenagers they say acting out
could be in forms of sexual behavior
drugs and alcohol use
signs of hurting themselves are also a
crisis situations that
they say should be addressed now there
are many resources available like
the knowchrist.com which is geared at
kids and teens
which is absolutely free now another
great resource
according to her is having an open
conversation with your doctor
teleservice are a common tool now
because of the pandemic
so check out eight newsnow dot com for
more resources christian gossett is
eight news now